foreign
all right
hopefully you're seeing me and hopefully
you're hearing me i'll find out
momentarily i'm sure
it's a pissed off aroma oh dear
oh dear should i be worried
what am i eating
strawberries
ah ms uh miss wicked wolf this is not a
choker
this is a caller
there is a difference
i own both
but
like that ace acorn it's a nice acorn
thank you i like it too
uh
hello all i'm not gonna i'm not i'm not
gonna catch everybody's name and say
hello to everybody like i want to but
i'm gonna miss some and feel bad that i
miss somebody
i want the collar where did you get it
well it's two different things the
collar itself
honestly might just be from amazon i've
had it for a while
um
the this is separate like this this i
could take off the collar easily enough
so this this was gifted to me
uh as a separate thing
looking pretty thank you adrian
hope everybody is doing well and
enjoying pride
oh adrenaline
oh that pun is terrible
bless you
i don't want june to end uh
i'll tell you what
not that i'm saying it makes me not want
to be in pride but you know
i i won't miss the far-right
hammering at us even harder than they
normally do just trying to counteract
the joy that we have in our own lives
i could never wear a collar like that
that's not for everybody
how's life
life is okay life is right now
incredibly work-centric
um
because uh next week i've got family
vacation that i'm taking and i won't you
know i have to
i have to be ahead
of my workload because i i won't be
working on stuff for five days so
it's uh
yeah
life is very
uh heads down in
work most of the time
and generally if i'm not worrying i'm
working i'm doing something else that i
need to be doing like
packing envelopes for stuff that i had
hoped to get mailed out by now but i'm
still working on
or yard work
because i've got oh god i've got to trim
the forsythia bush
uh
yeah there's there is
um
a lot of stuff
ah
i'm on family vacation next week too
well i hope you enjoyed it
i hope you will enjoy it not didn't do
i can thank
i went to our local pride fest a few
years ago had people lining up outside
the barricades to keep traffic out of
the parking lot to shout at people
attending
that generally doesn't happen around
here
um at least i've never encountered it
i feel like
one or
two people might have had like signs
but i don't ever recall anybody shouting
at us
i do remember
i think it was 2019
i remember the
the governor being at pride i don't like
this governor
uh very much but i remember him being at
pride and somebody going up and shaking
his hand and with a big smile on their
face saying to him go [ __ ] yourself and
uh that made me laugh
oh captain omni thank you so much
for the super chat well i have pride
news i'll be proposing to my girlfriend
at the end of pride last day yes i
believe
in going out with a bang
best of luck
um
i should remind people that while i do
try and keep up with the chat the only
thing that will guarantee that i see
um
[Music]
uh that i see your comment is by either
making use of the super chats which also
gets you a heart from me
um
but also um if you are in the discord
for the council of geeks patreon
then there is a channel devoted for that
where you can drop a question as well
those are the two ways
i live in a very red county of maryland
lots of trump and f bind signs around
around the county oh i'm not going to
say that i don't see those signs
sometimes but there's a very vermont
mentality
of i won't bug you if you don't bug me
like as far as getting up in people's
faces go
it's just not
it's not in the mentality
of most areas around here i'm not gonna
say none but not most so like you'll get
like most protests are sign holding
not an awful lot of shouting a lot of
sign holding
pride parade here in vancouver is on the
last day of july usually it's august not
sure why it's late here
events uh all summer through in the lead
up oh interesting
if neil patrick harris plays another
in-between doctor do we get to call him
dr hauser no
and he better not i can't imagine
they're gonna keep doing that like that
is that is a well that i think they need
to stop trying to
to pull anything useful from
uh
my water is now taking effect oh good
homebody i'm glad to hear it
uh
oh hey there jolie
the toy maker who's that oh someone very
fun i hope
i think nph has pretty much been
confirmed as the toy maker i mean like
i hear terms like basically confirmed
pretty much confirmed that's not
confirmed do i agree that that's most
likely who it is yes yes i do agree but
you know
to me
pretty much confirmed is still
unconfirmed
supreme omega thank you very much for
the super chat hello how are you
question
are there ways to kill off queer
characters without falling prey to
barrier gay stroke because ideally all
bets should be off
honestly the
the best way to counteract it
is
threefold now you don't have to do all
of these things but these are your
options
one this is honestly kind of the big one
for me this is the one that i kind of
really put my foot down on
they really shouldn't be the only gay or
queer character in a story
when the gay character or queer
character that you kill is the only
representation for queer people
that's
really hard to get away with at this
point first for someone like me
but
one of the few ways you can get around
that is if you're telling a story where
basically everybody dies so like if
you're doing
and then there were none or
the thing or something like where it's
clear that it's super indiscriminate to
the point that
virtually nobody's left alive that
might
have you get away with killing the only
gay character but if you're not doing
that not having them be the only queer
character that's the that's one thing
and then the other thing is
making sure that
being queer is not their most prominent
uh characteristic
because that's how you end up with stuff
like
resolution with chibnall where you have
a character basically show up
uh he confirms he has a boyfriend and
then is immediately killed so his
character and his personality as was
communicated to the audience was gay
that's literally the only thing we knew
about him
that's kind of the thing it's not that
you can't
kill queer people but like
it carries baggage you know how to
handle it
didn't the toy maker get reference and
can you hear me he did
he did i actually mentioned that in my
short
uh do you all think that the toymaker
could be why 10 is there i mean
maybe i don't know like he's got no
connections to 10 as it stands
but yeah suppose
i don't need to know the ages of movies
ms wicked wolf i do not need to feel any
older than i currently do thank you
kindly
i wouldn't be that surprised if uh nph
just came to set looking like geppetto
and rtd told him he needed to take a
selfie for the announcement he's
actually voicing beep the meep oh
goodness sake that whole thing
uh
i'm kind of i'm currently wearing
midnight black acrylic nails so sorry
for any typing errors
best of luck i don't do acrylic nails
like the the sensation of them really
does bother me
what are your thoughts on xeno warrior
princess i have seen very little of it
so i have
very few
um
probably yanto from torchwood is one of
the lesser problematic ways to kill a
gay character off i mean it helps that
by the time yanto dies
like two other members of the torchwood
team had who had already been killed
at that point and
i think they were both bi
so yanto
definitely isn't the first character
killed might not even be the first queer
character killed
almost everybody on that show is queer
so like that torchwood had a number of
things going for it
would you rather be a cyberman or a borg
i'm gonna go with borg i think both
would suck
but i suspect bo the uh
the assimilation into the borg
uh would be a lot less painful than the
cyber conversion so like i i figure each
life would be
equivalently crap
but
the the
difference being how bad is it getting
there
am i gonna see light year
i mean eventually
maybe probably i don't know i don't
i don't care
i don't i like i just i don't care
that's that's all it boils down to at
this point
uh i'm old enough to remember the
original power rangers given that i'm
actually only a year and about a week
younger than council of geeks
uh you'll be 40 soon
lucy lawless continues to be hot that i
will agree with that is an opinion i
will absolutely agree with
uh
i can't stay long ever rehearsal in 45
minutes just wanted to say happy pride
thank you nora i appreciate that
ever see the buffy movie i've been
saving it for the end of my buffy bridge
i'm halfway through angel
uh season five and i'm dreading my
re-watch i have seen the buffy movie
it's not very good
like if you're a fan of the tv show it's
kind of fascinating to see like
just just the concept the core concept
and the idea done badly
it's kind of just
i don't know academically interesting
i'd like for a better way to put it
do i support a football or a soccer team
[Laughter]
and true
[Laughter]
and true
i
i don't
care about sports
like any sport
at all
not a single one i find sports
really boring
it's not about the specifics of any
given game i find the the very nature of
sports to be
really boring and some of them are
boring in
very specific ways but broadly i find
all sports boring
the only exception i will make is that i
have kind of gotten into the marble
racing
uh on yellow's marble run
uh
that's about it though
uh
my first female crush was winnie from
wonder years didn't realize at the time
it was a crush though yeah that can
happen
have you watched skins uk nope
it does not seem like my jam at all i
have no interest what classic villain
villain do you want in the new doctor
who series omega
still always that will be the answer for
a long time
how would you rank the three big
franchise roles
uh indira varma has played susie and
torchwood
lyria sand
in game of thrones tala in obi-wan
i don't remember susie
from torchwood
and the sands were all wasted so by
default i'll say allah i'm sorry sorry
tala
yeah
brain fart
what about yu-gi-oh does that count as a
sport
i mean if you wanted to you can even if
you count that that does i still don't
like
sports stupid question but have you been
enjoying stranger things if you watch it
[Laughter]
um
i i have shot my review of stranger
things 4 i need to edit it
and upload it
but
uh mixed mixed is how i am on this
season let's go with that
do you remember queer as folk i remember
that it exists i've never watched it
either version
uh i heard a complaint that queer
characters
always play oppressed people would not
addressing homophobia and queer stories
be unrealistic
doing the community an injustice well it
depends on where the story's set and the
story being told so like
your
belief that it would be or at least your
um
proposed issue
uh that it would be unrealistic to not
address that presumes that the story is
set in the now and takes place
within a location
where homophobia is a prominent issue
but you know you're talking to a sci-fi
fantasy fan
who
you know my first thought is if you if
you have a story set anywhere other than
now or in the past of the world we live
in why is there homophobia i'm not
saying there can't be
but my first question is why
because it doesn't have to be
and i don't think it's a disservice to
tell stories without it if it makes
sense do not include it
but like
if you're gonna if you're gonna tell a
story in
uh a puritanical colony in the americas
in
16 something or other yeah there's gonna
be homophobia like to not depict it
would be uh incredibly strange
you need a really specific reason to not
do it but like i don't think it is by
any means required in order to tell a
gay story it just depends on where you
set it and what story you're trying to
do
supremo mega member for two months thank
you so much thoughts on jeff johns as a
writer pros and cons i have not read a
ton of his stuff
i know a fair amount of the kinds of
things he's done i admire his ambition
i admire his um
his sweeping scope and his ability to
wrangle the emotional core of most of
his stories
that having been said
uh
he can eat crap and choke for his
insistence on obliterating nearly all
legacy characters and bringing back
retired or dead ones in order to restore
a status quo that he grew up on that
wasn't the current one that the
readership was enjoying at the time
that's selfish and uh cruel
let's see
john vinyls thank you very much my
favorite thing about illyrio sand in
game of thrones is that in the book she
just wants the violence to stop and the
revenge cycle to end
that's interesting
there was um
there was nothing in that entire subplot
in the movies
that had any point really other than to
like
eventually kill off one of circe's kids
it's like the only thing with lasting
impact the entire
i can't
it's a dorn
what i can't even remember the name of
the place whatever the place is like
that entire subplot was
useless
she was the member of the torchwood team
or blew her brain's out in episode one
they got brought back to life oh
okay
all right
i do remember her now
uh oh i might go with that then now that
i remember
what are my thoughts on biopics i
usually find them
boring and a lot of them lean on the
well this is what really happened excuse
for
um a really terrible structure
most biopics are really badly structured
as stories
and they lean on the idea that they're
telling real life as a reason to not
have to structure a story properly
littlefinger on game of thrones was in
queer as folk the british one he was the
main one i think yeah i know that
because of a joke
that yassy crochet made when he did a
zero punctuation review on
quantum break
because he mentions uh how the the
character had a tendency to like in the
course of talking like sort of snake his
tongue out a bit
uh and i remember in the review he said
he really is the actor for whom snake
like uh was
was the term snake like was created he
certainly uses his tongue like a snake
it should have his own imdb page maybe
his tongue specifically unsettles me
because i remember all the [ __ ] it got
up to and queer as folk and i chose
those words very carefully
uh it's telling that so much fantasy and
sci-fi cannot imagine a word without
homophobia and sexism yeah i agree
adrenaline
yeah
i i
really i don't
i very sincerely don't like the fact
that a lot of
fantasy and sci-fi authors
assume a porting over of
the exact same kinds of prejudices and
uh oppression from the real world and
historically
would happen
in any world i'm like why
why
why do you assume that
so yeah it's frustrating
do you think the no one is allowed to be
happy problem is not just limited to
comics but also other long-term
franchises yeah i mean it's most
prominent in comics because comics i
think
um
as a medium especially superhero comics
like the entire
thing is all long-running
stories
um
so but if you were to to narrow it down
to other things that run for really long
times
uh whether it be
you know soap operas or even something
like james bond like james bond can't
ever be happy
james bond
was ever
in a happy relationship how like he
wouldn't be recognizable as james bond
so like it's not a um
it is a long-term storytelling problem
but since comics are intended to go on
indefinitely and
because they are cheaper to produce and
don't require you to
maintain actors and things like that
they have a much greater ability to go
on indefinitely it becomes more
prominent in comics than in a lot of
other media but yeah no it can affect
other things
is there any chance of you seeing the
thunderbolt series when it comes out
uh probably
i'm still waiting to find out more about
it but yeah probably
rocketman is a biopic and rocketman also
doesn't fall into the same structures i
didn't say i didn't like any biopics i
just thought i don't like most biopics
you could change one thing about peter
capaldi's interpretation of the doctor
what would it be nothing
i am not so
uh full of myself as to think that i
could
improve what he brought
what did i think of moon knight the last
episode was disappointing and
frustrating it felt really
really really uh rushed
it felt like i needed at least
one more episode if not two
thoughts on documentaries i find bbc
earth has some of the best i do like um
planet earth
documentaries i need to be in the right
mood for a documentary
um but they can be good
zero punctuation really does a number on
us i also knew about littlefinger
because of that joke
there you go
oh hey natalia oh thank you that's very
sweet long time listener first time
caller well welcome
welcome to the party
uh oh i've got some um
some super chess to get to
supreme omega how do you feel oh sorry
do you feel that uh coming out stories
can be overdone because
uh
aren't there
uh other issues queer people face that
relate to their sexuality and gender
identity um
i mean there are
like my
part of my boredom
with
um
coming out stories is that
it
by their nature they center the story on
the character's
queerness so the story is about them
being queer i'm not saying there's no
value in those stories like those
stories still should be told i'm not
saying those stories shouldn't
shouldn't keep being told but i'm saying
my interest
i am way more interested in a character
who
is queer
and also
this is happening to them
as opposed to
this is a story about their queerness
i like
i get hooked in on
silliness on monsters and spaceships and
uh fairies and
you know the the wood kind uh the
woodland kind and yeah so
i i would rather have a story about that
with queer characters in it than having
a story about queerness
are they overdone
i don't know it's hard for me to say
because like i said that's that genre
isn't really something i'm watching
anyway so i'm not really sure i'm in a
position to to say whether it's overdone
or not
i would kind of like to see mainstream
depictions start to move off and move
away from that like just take it as a
given yeah they came out at some point
and they clearly have some sort of
support structure we don't need to talk
about that we can pick it up from
context let's move forward
uh
how do you feel about the fact of the
who discourse is taken over by rtd leaks
when thirteen's era is not over yet
i bet it uh could leak me
uh i get it could
uh leak
oh sorry i get it could be leak
management but feels borderline
disrespectful like
things are just really tough right now
especially so
um
a lot of the filming for something like
doctor who
happens in public
spaces
it's a lot easier
for
you know hollywood
um or even marvel with the facilities
that it's built around atlanta
they have these
massive closed-off areas
that people just can't get close enough
to and so they can they can
keep a clamp on things a lot a lot
easier and of course anything on that's
shot on a green screen stage nobody's in
there who isn't supposed to be
for doctor who
or most uk stuff to be honest
they
like
they've got locations where people are
gonna see them
and
the leaks and the drops
yeah to a certain extent
let me put it this way i don't think rtd
is trying to step
on whitaker's exit
it is kind of what's happening though
um
[Music]
and that is unfortunate but at the same
time
sometimes this is what you have to do to
get ahead of the leaks because the the
leaks in something like doctor who are
are pretty bad
um especially when it comes to filming
like they're a little bit better on
scripts and uh overall ideas but um when
it comes to filming
yeah that stuff gets spotted and so
you're better off just getting ahead of
it
because it's going to be in the
conversation either way it's just a
question of whether or not you're in
control of it
at all
john vinyls thank you again
at ms wicked wolf it's really unfair how
willie scott
has every reason to be upset and scared
but the movie treats her
obvious undiagnosed general anxiety
disorder is a joke at a punchline ah
so we're talking um
uh temple of doom indiana jones the
temple of doom i really don't like that
movie
i would rather watch kingdom of the
crystal skull
than watch temple of doom i really don't
like temple of doom at all
the soundtrack's good
it's a couple of decent set pieces
i really don't like that movie
and willie's one of many reasons
initially i didn't like her because she
was annoying
and now as an adult i'm like it's like
why is this funny like the in the the
film is very cruel which is something
that both um
lucas and
uh spielberg
sort of acknowledged looking back on it
because
um
i think lucas was in the middle of his
divorce
when they were working on it like just
the tone of it is it's it's just kind of
a cruel movie
what are my thoughts on the sly cooper
games never played them no idea
preemptive safe and happy travels thank
you homebody i appreciate that
torchlight remember villains think
they're the hero most of them do i do
think there is fun to be had in a
villain who knows they're the villain
it it the the trick is just to not
uh
use that as a way to skimp out on
characterization so like if you want a
really good example
you can go to shakespeare you look you
can look at characters like aaron lamore
from titus andronicus or richard iii
from richard iii these are characters
who are well aware that they are the
villains
of
with everything going on
but they're really great and compelling
characters because their
understanding of that about themselves
isn't an excuse to not fully flesh them
out that's part of their
characterization it says a lot about
them
that they would rather lean into what
they know is villainy with no
rationalization no it's okay because
just be just
like yeah
i'm okay being the villain in this story
and what that says about them as people
you have to construct that very
carefully but it can absolutely work
i missed a chat oh uh what did i miss
uh
herbie herbivar
varsawas thank you very much for the
super chat i appreciate that
thoughts on superheroes becoming parents
some people say
it's never done right i disagree and i'm
still wanting for spider dad i
absolutely disagree that it's never done
right the problem is
because there is rather frequent
turnover for writing staff and even
editorial staff
the problem is that
it almost never keeps
because a later writer will come around
and decide they don't want to write a
kid and retcon it or
you know erase it or
kill off people or whatever
like
i think there are good stories
out of heroes becoming parents i think
sometimes those stories even get told
but they almost never stay or never
stick
and like i do understand it from the
sense of these characters are kind of
meant to never age and just go on
forever but at the same time like you're
cutting off a lot of storytelling
potential out of the constant status quo
resets
but i go so far to say i hate temple of
doom no but i don't like it
do you have any interest in the joker
sequel or nah nah
like i'll probably see it out of morbid
curiosity but
i didn't think the first one was very
good and that's one of those movies that
like people tore into me
for not praising that movie
which is just irritating
i don't care
if you think i'm an idiot because i
didn't like it it's just annoying to
have to clear out my comments because
i'm determined to keep it civil as best
as i can
speaking of temple of doom it's a real
joy seeing
uh ke hoi kwon getting great reviews for
his performance and everything
everywhere all at once i still want to
see that
sean tweeted today he's working on part
four bbc video hopefully to release
tomorrow i knew he would like i knew he
was going to do a follow-up
which will probably render my own
breakdown of the bbc response um
moot and redundant because he'll
probably do it better and more
thoroughly but you know
i did it first
yay i don't know
would you include maleficent in the
category or is she not fleshed out
enough well i mean like she's a literal
cartoon villain
she is appropriately fleshed out for the
story she's in
thoughts on superman as a dad i thought
that was a great idea
because for somebody as as deeply
principled as him
you know
being the paragon and trying to balance
what he's trying to do to to
help humanity
while
being a good father i thought that was a
great idea
i haven't read a lot of the stuff but i
thought that was a great idea
i just realized coming out stories are
so plentiful because it's the aspect of
queerness system people are mostly
exposed to
yeah
yeah that's true sam and like part of
that is
it treats queerness itself as unusual
because if you just had them as queer
and didn't do a coming out story and
they're just there
it treats queerness as normal
and apparently that is far more radical
for some goddamn reason
are you talking about uk queers folk
original us queers folk or new queers
folk
i forget they're doing a new one oh good
grief
my favorite video game i mean
nostalgically it's final fantasy vi i
don't know if it would actually remain
that if i went back and replayed it but
nostalgically yeah
honestly i want to see it after i found
out it was lady gaga musical and it
stopped most of its fans i mean like
that
look we'll see i thought the i thought
the original had its head really far up
its own ass
um
and i don't have a lot of respect for
todd phillips as a director
um
[Music]
but
yeah we'll see
we'll see
how does you're being served
still go goodness i remember watching
that uh reruns of that when i was a kid
ah john vinyls
thank you very much
temple of doom would have worked better
if the villain was a colonial british
officer
misusing hindu magic for his own powers
it would have helped
but like let's be honest all of the
indiana jones uh stories carry
even the good ones carry an overtone of
colonialism with them
because it's kind of inherent to the
treasure hunting genre
because you got a white guy going into
places that are not his country to
remove artifacts
from the land which they belong
that's
what the genre is
so like there's inherent problems
i still like treasure hunting stories
but like that's a problem inherently
have i played any of the persona games i
have persona 5 on my ps3 i think i
booted it up once i didn't really get
very far
uh kehua kwon also played
uh data in the goonies yeah i figured
that was him
i would suggest watching superman lowest
but i don't but i know you don't like
family dramas so don't i don't have the
time
to watch that one i really oh i super
don't supreme omega thank you very much
for the super chat how come bully and
mean girl uh getting a redemption arc is
prevalent and popular just look at
cordelia and buffy flash thompson in the
spidey comics
um
i think there's a couple reasons
um the the first is i think a lot of
writers enjoy the challenge of trying to
redeem a character i think redemption
stories by their nature have an appeal
and beyond that if the characters stick
around long enough
you kind of have to start to lend depth
to them if they're going to remain
interesting at all and the more depth
you lend to a bully or mean goal
character the more
shades you're gonna bring the more
uh aspects and the less shallow they
become and then that's sort of just a
gradual drift towards them becoming
better people
what did todd phillips do
he didn't do anything i just don't think
he's a particularly good director
and again he had his head really far up
his own ass
i remember him talking about joker about
how it wasn't a comic book movie it was
a real movie and like just piss off dude
if you think you're too good for the
source material you're working with go
go somewhere else
i i don't i have i have no time for
people who show contempt for source
material or contempt for
uh adjacent genres in which they are
working
i'm not saying he has to i'm not saying
he's not allowed to think that he can
think whatever he wants but that's a
[ __ ] thing to say out loud
apropos of absolutely nothing finally
found a lord of the ring channel host
with a sense of humor who agreed that
yes
uh phaser one would indeed destroy the
ring
ah they had to be out there somewhere
i imagine it must be hard for indigenous
folks to watch treasure hunting stories
i would imagine there's a lot of stuff
uh that is probably hard for and or at
least frustrating for indigenous folk
but i'm also it's not my place to speak
for them so
speak any spanish
no
i took spanish
for
two years
two or three
i think two
two years i took two years of spanish in
high school i don't remember a thing
i remember nothing
the columnist and newspaper it was oh so
that's in relation to something else on
australia gossip columnist
contacted rebel to let her know they
were writing a story about her new
relationship with a woman she announced
the relationship on insta before it got
published oh the thing with rebel wilson
yeah
the columnist in the newspaper it was
linked to then got into a huff that they
couldn't leak the news considering the
columnist was gay himself that was
surprising i don't find uh amos i
actually don't find that surprising at
all
um
if you know who perez hilton is
then you should know how
very easy it is for people to prioritize
their career over
people that they should in theory
um
be able to empathize with
but like
i don't know who this person is and i
don't know if specifically what i'm
about to say applies to this person so i
understand that
but
if you're a bottom feeding scumbag uh
reporter then it doesn't really matter
if you're gay or not
oh
thank you carolyn uh john viles you
needed a heart for that last
super chat
um purple raider
you get a heart as well no comment or
statement just wanted to let you know
you're great and you are loved thank you
i appreciate that
my secret goal is to get beard to use
more yiddish expressions
thank you for uh clipping that carowind
much appreciated
uh
oh let me just stretch real quick
discord yes caroline let me just take
care of john's newest super chat
thank you john
shakespeare villains
could you do
reimagining of merchants of venice or
the tempest where porsha is an
antagonist figure where or where
prospero is the villain
i don't know merchant of venice well
enough you could make prospero the
villain very easily
uh
you do a little tweaking you make
caliban
you tweet caliban so he is less
uh of a villainous figure in terms of
his backstory
um
and you make prospero more of uh just
an oppressive controlling dick
who's
mad at having lost power yeah prospero
can be can be the villain real easy in
the tempest real real easy
i'm performing on my first pride this
saturday any tips on how to handle it
focus on what it is you're doing
and people will love you for it you'll
be fine
all right
uh
i need to hop on over to the discord
see what we've got here we have got oh
we've got a few okay
people have been making a lot more use
of this lately okay
uh the boiling isles are a made-up
fantasy setting so so this is from owl
house so dana terrace can just make it
so there's no bigotry against queer
people here but what about when amity
and luce visit the real world if you
were writing owl house would you have
the characters encounter homophobia on
earth or would you just ignore it the
other week i posted this question on the
owl house subreddit and several people
told me having them encounter bigotry on
earth would undermine the show's attempt
to make queer kids feel included and
normal even if it would be realistic i'm
kind of inclined to agree
i would say that
whether or not it would feel unrealistic
to not address it would have to do with
what it was that they did
while on earth
so like if they mainly are just
encountering say lucy's mother
um
then i don't think there's a need to
make a big problem out of that
um but also keep in mind i haven't seen
the end of season two yet because it's
not on uh disney plus so if if there's
something that's happened that i don't
know about don't tell me please
but yeah i'm overall inclined to agree
with that assessment that a big part of
the point of the show is to normalize
all these things and so
even
if you could make an argument for
realism
[Music]
to um
you know that it it's a reason to
reintroduce homophobia under certain
circumstances here's the thing realism
is not the end-all be-all nor should it
ever be know what story you want to tell
and tell it you are not obligated to be
quote unquote realistic if if it comes
down to a conflict between
is this realistic and is this
the story i want to
tell as long as the way in which you are
bending or playing with uh
realistic aspects isn't in direct
contradiction to what your own story has
been doing
throw realism out the window
if it's gonna completely bum out the
entire thing to hell with it and anyone
who would who might try and argue well
kids should understand the realistic um
you know
oppression or uh disrespect they'd
receive being queer i'm like they
already know
they need they they need
they need to see support right now they
don't need to see that depicted in their
entertainment because they see it in
reality believe me
a stranger things episodes too long
yeah
actually
they are i
i don't like it and the same thing
happened to hbo with the tail end of um
game of thrones
i don't think
that it's a net gain for shore runners
to be told
make the episodes however long you need
them to be
because i think there is a lot of good
that happens
from the streamlining of making
something fit a set amount of time
as opposed to just tacking on 15 minutes
because you can
maybe the story would be better if you
drop those 15 minutes or real or
reallocate them across multiple episodes
as a running b plot or something else
i
even as a creative myself i don't think
working with no restrictions is good for
creativity i think
creativity thrives within certain kinds
of constraints
and i think run times on episodes
is usually
better
for these things than to just take it
off and go hey you know make the episode
however long you want which is what
season 4 has been like and i don't care
for it
uh do you think it's particularly
realistic
that someone like steve harrington
uh we just have no bigotry against
lesbians whatsoever i wasn't alive in
the 80s and i never lived a small town
in america so i don't know
i
is it realistic
i don't know
i also don't care
cause it's awesome and it's one of the
best scenes from season three her coming
out to him and him just kind of taking
this pause
and pivoting
and shifting from thinking he had a
romantic interest to being just like her
friend
it's too good to be bogged down in
realism like that's the thing i don't
care
if that's unrealistic
don't take that moment away it's
great besides the fact that since then
the
you know it's not like it's acted like
nothing has
uh has any sense of homophobia about it
she's obviously nervous about letting a
girl she has a crush on no they're
nervous about other people knowing you
know so like there's still an
acknowledgement of it but there isn't
steve
steve is
a bit of a doofus
but ultimately he does
you know he cares about people and well
he cares about some people and he cared
about robin and
i would also argue that i think it's
unrealistic for him to suddenly drop
someone he was drawing close with over
something that he probably would readily
admit he doesn't fully understand
again if you want to argue me it's
unrealistic i don't care
i really super don't
in a fantasy setting would you say that
trans characters should be able to have
magic spells transition them provided
the magic in the setting is capable of
that or would you say would be best to
simulate something closer to real life
or perhaps supposed to keep the effects
going like in real life i think it's up
to the writer
like
do what you want it's like that's the
beautiful thing about fantasy it's all
an option
would it be better to do one or the
other i don't know it depends on the
story you intend to tell with these
characters in the setting you create
overall so like
there's a trans character in my novel
and i don't go explicitly into how this
works
but she is
effectively on my world's equivalent of
hormone replacement therapy
and that for her that is an ongoing
thing that's how i chose to do it but
that's also because the story that i
wrote doesn't you know humans don't have
command of magic they can't just do
whatever they want
so
um that wasn't even an option that i
considered for her
but other people in terms of stories and
how magic works and how they want to do
it do whatever you want
like i i think which of those is the
better option would have would be more
reflective of what kind of world you
want to build and what kind of magical
capacity do you want the characters to
have
as an acepan romantic in terms of sexual
orientation i feel kind of bad that the
scope of ace representation is basically
up to five characters most of those
being serial killers or slackers um yeah
verb people say that it's hard to do an
ace character because it's basically
showing nothing but i hate that idea
yeah i i reject that framing
completely like speaking of someone who
is not ace but also really hates
romantic subplots
i do not consider the lack of romantic
interest for a character to be showing
nothing i consider that a god damn
blessing because it eliminates a
complete range of subplots that 99 times
out of 100 i am bored by or hate
so
more ace characters please all over the
place left and right in inject ace
characters so that we can have less
romantic subplots
please
do you think we'll ever see a reboot of
hercules legendary journeys perhaps one
that showcases hercules bisexual nature
from myth i still love that show still
dude despite kevin sorbo turning out to
be a walking talking pile of human fecal
matter yeah he's a real he's
not getting into him
um
i don't think you would need to reboot
it i would say like
you know the hercules legends are public
domain anyone can do a re a
re-adaptation of them in tv or movie
form or
i think we're due for another crack at
it because like because we had we had
that with that movie with dwayne johnson
a little while back didn't do too well
it's
i think i think it's time to try it
again uh on screen i don't think it's
necessary to tie it to that franchise
but i mean if you can get the rights
sure go ahead
do you think stargate needs to come back
to add another contender to the star
wars aka the battle between sci-fi
franchises that have star in their name
um
i didn't watch anything of stargate
other than the movie
so i don't know if it's worth bringing
back
but strictly for that strictly as a
third party candidate
yeah sure why not
have you read the trans superhero novel
called dreadnought i really liked it i
have not i've not heard of that so nope
can't say that i have
i'm guessing that a review of the mind
robber is in the offing considering some
of the rumors i've heard regarding neil
patrick harris and doctor who by the way
currently having heat index of 108
fahrenheit help me oh my gosh
i'm really sorry about that
um
like if
so if
if neil patrick harris ends up being the
master not the master but like the
master from the mind robber which isn't
the same master it was a different
character who was called the mask
if you've seen it you know
yes i would take a i would take a look
back at that i have seen it but i would
need to watch it again before i could do
a review on it
uh
oh
okay so someone posted one of those like
those nine by nine like it's weird
messed up face it was like jar jar binks
in a dress and you run it i don't
actually know what the heck that is that
everyone's using
it's weird and off-putting and i don't
get it
uh
[Music]
it's almost 120 degrees fahrenheit here
oh my gosh perry good grief
stay safe wondering if we could get some
relatively brief thoughts on how queer
fans should navigate visibility in
fandom spaces in this month of all
months in this year of all years
meant mostly in whovian comics fans but
more broadly means so you don't have to
just retread the
bbc warnings and since i'm ace for the
furries i prefer my case stories to be
cold dishes not knots
okay
um
the thing is you know me doing the uh
the warnings about the bbc is not
about visibility it's about
accountability
it's about not letting
either the company
or the people who might support them get
away with
just acting like it didn't happen and
was never properly addressed
that's what that's about um
i think i i appreciate that a lot of
fan and
um geek spaces
uh often whether it be discords or comic
con conventions will often
carve out uh specifically queer friendly
areas or events um i think i think
that's honestly a really positive thing
and it's
it helps it helps a lot
have you seen the show everything's
gonna be okay i have not
so uh sorry i don't have anything more
to add to that
uh as an autistic person myself i don't
think i ever related to an autistic
character and a piece of media
this much oh i mean that's great and the
actress the actress is autistic well
that's awesome
but no i haven't seen it
going purely by aesthetics favorite
pride flag i'd have to go with asexual
flag trans flag is a close second
but whatever i look at it
i just think pastels um
hang on let me let me
pull
let me pull a list up here
all right so if we're going purely by
aesthetics
um
like honestly
this is partially
self-indulgence i really like the gender
fluid colors
but i also kind of i also like the
progress flag i i think that's one of
the instances where the added sort of
triangle and arrow features work well
i'm
a little bit mixed on them in some of
the other flags like in
some of the demi flags
but i think they work really well
there so okay i've got a couple more
geez i might have to start uh
either planning to have these uh streams
run longer or
um jump over to the discord earlier
because folks folks didn't used to use
it all that much and now it's being used
a lot
slight tangent by the way imagine if
dana terence had made bellows a woman
in brisballona maybe
and gave her a bachelor of being a tall
blonde aristocratic woman either
scottish highland clan descent or some
bastard daughter of the visconti of
milan
who manipulated schemed her way onto the
boiling island's aristocracy then
proceeded to take over as empress formed
a which supremacist ideology that
oppresses subjugated the native magical
creatures and also she's especially
determined to destroy loose for
acquiring magic rather than being born
with it i mean that's an option i mean
at that point you basically written fan
fiction because it's it's such a
divergence
um
but it's not a it's not an awful pitch
given that the latter is charting
wuthering heights or
running up that hill
uh running up that hill please
uh let's see
uh regarding antagonist porsche my idea
would be less porsche as a vicious evil
karen and more porsha is basically
well-meaning-ish person who's unaware of
shylock's full situation and is blinded
by her own white christian privilege
interesting
interesting all right i've got a couple
more and people are typing out more of
them
i think this is just going to start
becoming like a
an hour
plus
stream
if this keeps up
uh was steve a total jerk in season one
or was his response to jonathan somewhat
understandable like jonathan was taking
pictures of people without consent i
think
steve's anger at jonathan was pretty
understandable i think physically
assaulting jonathan made steve the jerk
regardless
um
at what age should you start telling
kids they can't necessarily to put a
mildly trust the government to do the
right thing
i feel like with
really little kids you just can't tell
them the police are evil or some of the
stuff their teachers say to them may not
be accurate for practical reasons
uh like they won't know what to do with
that information when does that change
well
when that change
has a lot to do with who you are
because
you know as a um
[Music]
as a white person i am aware
of the fact that
it's pretty common for black parents to
have to have quote unquote the talk with
their kids particularly their sons
about how
they have to be really careful around
police otherwise the police will shoot
them
so i think at what point you need to
start
breaking those
assumptions
really kind of depends on the situation
that you live in because that's gonna
impact at what age is it more important
that they know the reality
than
um
you know uh
just be kind of cruising along and i
know there are those who would argue
that you know you should never lie to
kids and always tell them the truth but
the thing is the the truth is
super nuanced and super confusing
and this is not me saying that like oh
kids are easily confused
kids
as they grow up will be
they will shock you with how well they
are able to absorb nuance
but they can't do that right from the
get-go
so
i think again this is going to vary
parent by parent and living situation by
living situation
um
but you have to be
you have to be careful about not over
instilling a trust in an authority that
you will later have to
um help them come to question
but also it can be counterproductive to
instill such a distrust of authority
that they
like basically are
rebellious to the point of not being
able to just function day-to-day in the
society that they're in
and knowing how to balance that is gonna
vary wildly from parent to parent what i
can tell you about my own kid
is i don't
think i'm gonna have to like i might
eventually have to have a talk
or some kind of talk
with her about police
um
but
i don't think i'm ever gonna have to
talk to her about the fact that the
government doesn't always have the
interest of the people at hand because
you know it's
even like as a as a kid and just knowing
the generalities not being super plugged
into the specifics
she knew
very young that trump was a jerk
like she knew that we didn't have to
tell her that she knew that on her own
she was she was quite young
and
she was like four
four or five
and
uh she was
no she would have been
she would have been five
when
uh hillary lost
and
she wasn't happy about that
because and if i remember the quote
directly
the other guy seemed mean i think she'd
maybe seen like two minutes of a debate
or something
i don't have to tell her that you can't
always trust the government because she
has she has grown up
with four years of
seeing someone in the white house who
she instinctively did not trust i don't
have to teach that to her
she got there on her own
uh
suggestions set up a google form for
discord questions uh open it up an hour
or two before it's easier to organize
the live versus discord time
maybe but except like with my brain
um
adding more components in is dead like
it's it's counteractive for how my brain
works
i'm thinking of basing a superhero on
their sexual orientation is a terrible
idea unless that superhero was asexual
for example ace man captain ace
commander ace the ace of spades the list
goes on
uh even those who are pan-romantic or
pansexual since you got the parody idea
of pan man who uses pants to fight crime
i'd read a web comic of that sure
uh the main thing i wanted to convey in
the female bellows is the idea of her
being a vicious supremacist who has a
specific hatred to people
uh of people who changed what she sees
as their essential nature ah
okay i get what you were going for yeah
that would certainly work allegorically
uh as a villain okay i'm done with the
discord and i'm coming back let's see i
am
i've got two um super chats
uh
so let's see john vinyls fun fact the
rtd version of a midsummer night's
stream actually makes
theseus the villain of the story
interesting
cause that
that story doesn't really have a villain
it has trouble makers it doesn't really
have a villain though
huh interesting
and uh strom dynasty what do you think
of stranger things as representation i
think for being set in the 80s they
handle it quite well i like robin
immensely
i wish they would confirm what the hell
they're doing with will
lots of people read him as gay i have
always read him as ace
but i wish they'd confirm what in the
hell they're doing
because this uh
this whole dancing around being like oh
well we're gonna imply no do it if he is
something tell us what he is let it be
actual representation
so that is annoying me
do i prefer dresses or skirts i don't
have a strong preference one or the
other
i like them both
particle man vs triangle man
they have a fight triangle wins triangle
man
[Music]
two
uh who's my favorite character from
stranger things that's probably still
steve
will better be out by the season 4
finale again like
my read on will is is ace
um like a lot of people at the end of
season three read will's kind of
trying to reach out to
or his frustration with mike you know as
mike was kind of
um moving away from the things they used
to do together a lot of you read that as
will crushing on mike i read that as
mike being pulled away by puberty and
his attraction to l
and will not feeling those kinds of
feelings at all and not understanding
why they can't keep having what they
used to have because he's not being
pulled away by the same kinds of things
that mike is that was my read i think
either one works but at this point they
are really implying that will is
something
and you know
just confirm it just confirm it
because it's not representation if you
don't confirm it not at this point there
was a time
10
15 years ago
where the implied representation was
about as good as we got we are no longer
living in that time if you're actually
representing it then have them be the
thing
i suspect stranger things is either not
going to address his sexuality or give
him a very clumsy gay coming out i don't
expect them to make him ace at all yeah
i don't either but that's still my read
until proven otherwise not that i think
there's anything wrong with the idea of
him being gay it's just that was my read
and i'm sticking to it until
uh reality bumps me out of it
captain omni thank you once again did
you know judge dredd is canonically
lgbtqa
while not confirmed does anything
specific did romantically embrace
another man and a kiss in an issue
that's cool
i did not know that about dread
i'm i'm i the only reason i'm slightly
surprised is that dread is so
job-focused
i'm kind of shocked he has a room in his
brain
for romantic inclinations or sexual ones
but hey
sure why not
uh
following up on that particle man or
instant bull not constantinople i mean i
like istanbul better as a song because
it's i like its uh its energy
strom dynasty i always thought hopper
was a great positive male he's pretty
good he's pretty solid
i still like steve a little bit better i
mentioned that in the positive
masculinity video i did a couple years
ago
that like steve's journey and do
positive masculinity i [ __ ] i love it so
much but hopper's pretty solid
uh john vinyls thank you again so will
is autistic and is frustrated that mike
isn't into their shared special interest
yeah viably
yeah potentially
that works
that 100 works
still salty over jughead not being ace
and riverdale seriously
that was messed up
that was real messed up
i mean i try not to get too salty about
riverdale because it's too stupid to be
worth getting salty over but yeah that
come on come on
okay
around 15 minutes over my normal time i
think that's pretty decent
i thought about watching stranger things
but finding about out about the violence
and gore made me go maybe not yeah like
it's not
it is very horror and while it's not
prolifically violent it is frequently
violent and pretty gorilly so
hopper is a good example of trying to do
better speaking of jesse's video about
james gunn is amazing yes i've seen most
of it i haven't had the time to watch
all of it but i also know about uh james
gunn uh himself popping into her chat
which
oh man
like she's just she's
she's too good at this
she's making connections just
doing just by being really good at what
she does
[Laughter]
all right
that's it for that
uh robin hobb's
realm of the elderling series has a
major character who reads very ace also
gender fluid or non-binary not sure
which was written mostly in the 90s
surprising for the times oh that's nice
yes carowind thank you for the reminder
so
uh twitch
tomorrow at uh 10 30 uh eastern time
uh i will be continuing to play pyre
which i am enjoying
uh and also tomorrow uh the take two
review for resolution will go up at
about noon eastern time
and
finally uh there will be a review of the
new episode of
uh ms marvel up sometime in the
afternoon i don't know exactly when
because i'll have to watch it shoot a
review and then edit that
so
uh i literally know almost no ace
characters where are they there aren't
there aren't a lot like um
asexual you you have to deal with a lot
of headcanon i had a conversation
uh with kyra the scrivener uh she wasn't
using that
that uh name yet
but
i had that conversation with her
years ago
on the channel we talked for a while
about that
um
but anyways uh supreme omega getting in
there at the last minute sneaking in one
more super chat much appreciated on
identity crisis in spite of its flaws
how come it was popular and sold well
to the point wizard called it most
talked about event of 2004.
excuse me
it sold well because it was shocking
because the mystery was intriguing
and
um
because it was really unexpected
it
i don't think it so well in spite of its
flaws i think a lot of the people at the
time and some people even now
still don't see the flaws as flaws
or not as very big ones
uh i think they're huge and i think
identity crisis is
uh terrible
i don't think it's a very well written
story and
i think it is
uh
morally abhorrent
in terms of the damage done to the
characters involved
so
you know
but not everyone not everyone gets there
some people some people thought it was
cool and edgy and said interesting
things i thought it just said a more
extreme version of things that comics
were saying left and right since the
late 80s so
oh hey meg
look at you sneaking in here at the last
minute
john vinyl hell one more you you i tr
try to try to wrap it up you folks bring
me back in
more on shakespeare villains the villain
in romeo and juliet is the feud itself
and the villain in twelfth night is
heteronormativity
i support those readings
uh
yeah
may you are just in time for
things to wrap up and i i am glad you
stopped in though it's good to see you
uh
i watched your conversation with the ace
woman very recently you're hearing that
you're hearing that video was fantastic
thank you
but yes i'm glad i am going to
wrap it up
um so thank you all for joining me have
a good rest of pride
um and
please remember that
you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned